私はコンピューターグラフィックスの研究尾長で行ってきました
ん
コンピュータグラフィックス今ではゲームでもええテレビ映画でも見かけるこの
テクノロジーなんですけれどもそのバックグラウンドでは映像として作り出すための形
ですね
形をどのようにして作り出すかそういったことが大事な技術になってきます
また一方で cg ではどんなものでも
できてしまうのでそれを実際に世の中に存在するような実物にしようとそれとまたもう
少し考えなければならないことが出てきます
cad と呼ばれるソフトウェアがありますけれども世の中にあるものを設計する
そういったことを支援するためのソフトウェアそのようなものがあって
私は大学に入った時にはこのものづくりのためのソフトへの研究ということもやってき
ました
また私の子供時代さかのぼると私は神工作が大好きな少年でしたので紙でモノを作ると
いうことをよくやってたんだ
このコンピューターを使ってものの形を設計するといった時に紙で作れる形とはどの
ようなものかな
それを設計するためにはどうすればいいからそんなことを
博士の論文にまとめるということは言ってきました
さてその後ですねもっとチャレンジングなことは何だろう
紙で作れるか
館の中でもっと難しいことその中におり玩具というものがあったわけです
1枚の紙をこれだけで作れる形
それがおりあるということになるわけですけどもこの1枚の紙を切らないからない俺
だけでできる形にはどのようなものなのかそういうものを研究するということはとても
エキサイティングなことです
皆さんが折り紙といったときにどのようなものを想像するかというともちろん最初に
ホーリーするというものが頭に浮かぶでしょ
それから子供の時に寄った兜やこと位
このようなものがまずおりガムして床の形だと思います
ではこのようなおり学官一体いつぐらいからにもんで
おられるようになってきた
その歴史についてちょっと振り返ってみると
200年以上前だされた
9件早雲閣というものが今実際にの掘っている最も古い
折り紙に関する
取材する文系になるというふうに言われています
三重県の桑名市で発見されたこの
そ噴火口という本はそのタイトルにするというキーワードが入っていうことからわかる
ように
毛利鶴を作るということが前提その鶴の綱れたような状態で
レンズるに関して書かれた本です
でその中の文字としてこのような技術があるんですけどもまぁ私の専門家ではないので
ちょっと芸術に読み取ることは難しいんですけどももクロパッと見てみるとここに
折り鶴という言葉があります
折り鶴を子どもの遊びであるというふうにがして捨ててしまうのはなんともったいない
ことであろうかというようなことが書かれているわけですね
今日私が皆さんにお伝えしたいことは申すで100年以上前から言われてことと全く
変わりません
鬼神は折り鶴止まりと思ってしまうととてももったいねもっともっと奥深いものがあり
ますよということを今日はお伝えしたいと思います
英語の折り鶴ですけれどもおった後着替えてみたことがある人はどれくらいいる
でしょうか
折り鶴を開くと展開図山すっぽり
谷折りの線が現れます
でこのような展開図と元の形はどういう関係をしているかなということをよくよく
調べるというのが一つの折り紙の研究の作家たりになります
私は最初に述べたようにコンピュータグラフィックスは使う人間ですので
パソコンの上で形を設定してそれの展開図がどのようになるだろうか
またその逆に展開図を設計してあげて立体的な形がどうなるかそんなことを調べてです
ね
実際にやっぱりものとして世の中に出すということはとても楽しい髪を手で
触りながらものを作れば楽しいことなので実際の
そういうことができるとですね私の一番下の息子の頭にかぶせて阿蘇沿いとかですね
こんな楽しいことが出ている
そういうことを
楽しくやって今まで折り紙体験できたと思う
私がやっている折元へというのはその伝統的な苦味と帰る違いまして
今回入口のところに展示もさせてもらいましたけども
このような曲線での檻を各6立体的な造形ですね
これをどうやって
生み出すことができるだろうかそのようなことはをコンピューターを使ってまたその
背景には数学的な話をしながらということで作り出しています
今まで喋ったないを少し今ここで整理しますと
折り紙は子供の遊びであると多くの方が思ってこられたと思います
しかしながら長い歴史があって日本に根付いた文化であるということもできます
また綺麗に仕上げて現実ではアウト作品と踏み出すこともできるかもしれません
しかし今日ここでお話ししたい大事なキーワードは
規格であるその半径にあるちょっとした
算数のもしくは数学と言えるようなことを理解
すると新しい発見が出てきますので今日はその内容を少し説明したいと思う
折り紙の幾何学はとてもカンタンです山森とたによりの2種でしたありません
出てくる戦というのはここで赤と青でしました
山おい産業その2種類だけです
ですからこのような山谷山たりが交互に並ぶ線を与えられた場合はこのような者が治り
ができるということになりますし
このような斜めにいただい違いに行く
赤い線と縦に1本青い線が与えられたときにこれを持ってくださいと言うとたいていの
人はこの形を作り出すことができるわけです
でこの形なんですね第団に折りたたむことができまして
今動画でてますけれどもパターンとたたんで三角形を俺
ような感じ
さてここでクイズですかあいらに折りたたま出る展開図はこんな感じでどれでしょう
ちょっとだけ考えてみてくださいどれも似たような感じで赤い山をイノセント
青い何よりの性が出てきますが
正解はこちら左下の展開するだけが大量に畳まれます
さてどうしてそういうことがわかるのかという事ですがここで
2つの法則を皆さんにお教えします
一つ目は前川邸という名前がついている
大量に畳まれる
展開図の法則です
山折線と尿理性の数を数えてみます
そうすると
違いだにだけある
いうことです山折りが4本何よりが日本であれば4-8-2
ひっくり返すと谷が4本になる
その差はに必ずなるということ
もう一つ川崎ていると呼ばれるものがあります
これは角度に注目しています
一つ解いの角度をか死産していくと180度になるというとてもシンプルなすっきりし
たという
ですねこのような条件を満たすものは
タイヤに折りたたまれるというふうなルールがあるので
これを知った上でもう一回これを見てみると
山谷の数だけに注目してあこれはダメダメだというふうに条件に合わないものを外して
言ってこれが残るということがいえるわけです
実際にほらなんかでも分かってしまうそんな風に考えるとですね先ほど見せした単純な
パターンぬふので
折りたたまれるんだなじゃあこれを平らに隣り合わせに並べてしまったものもお礼と
いうことはみなさんすぐ気づかれると思います
実際に並べた状態のものを
こんな風に作って動かしてみます
そうすると
蛇腹のようにですねを得たためもだけ参加っていう
ではということで今折りたたんだもの今度は縦に並べてに
こんな感じですねちょっと半分がケツ出してやると
新しく出てくるを伊勢集まりも先ほどの2通りのルールを満たすのでこれたように
折りたたまれるんだなということに気付き
でこれを正方形に収まるしてりさ様というところだけますね
じゃあ実際にお礼のかなというふうによっ
いうと
最初法院でここのある状態ですが確かにですね牛といったターンを平らにすると参加型
がなどような形になりますね
ねま手を離さこのようなもと喪女
になります
さてさてじゃあもうなるほどあとはコピーペーストで増やしてやればいいやということ
に気づきますね
猫へていっぱいパターン並べても実際に作れちゃう
万手を離した状態だったとこういう綺麗な花たち
違うあげとこうということでこれも一つの新しい折り紙の表現かなというふうに思わ
れるかもしれません
ということで今私が何を言いたかったかというと折り紙を開くとやまたりの展開図が
現れますがその逆の発想で山たりの低解像上手にレイアウトしてあげるとまた新しい形
が生まれてくるというそういう可能性がありますのでぜひ皆さん
この折り紙の展開1いうものを4億感謝
移すそうすると何か新しい発見があるんじゃないかなと
立案てそんなに簡単な私じゃなくて実際に折りたたんでるけどた人髪がぶつかっちゃっ
ておれないよということはあります
そのときにじゃあどういう風に犯人と官民の重なり順を決めればいいの
これは実は数学指難しい問題で
コンピューターの手を上げて解決しようという心にも私は過去に行ったことがありまし
たでこのソフトウェアはインターネット上でも公開しているんですけども
展開図を山谷の情報を持たせた展開図を入れるとこれ本当に折りたたまれるのっていう
のをチェックしますそのチェックを通ったものが実際に置いたたんだろストーカー
3の重なり順も含めて全部計算で出すということをやってくれるのでこういうツールが
あるといいですね
ますバスおりガールの研究
餓死するということですで今お話ししたのはちょっと来いストライドの文字が刀とって
いるので申し訳ないんですけども平らにより
畳まれるものでした泥炭老神
でこれも立体的にしましょうというのがまた次のステップへ
一体的にするってちょっと難しいかなと思うかもしれないですけど
実はとっても簡単なんですある場所に注目した時に狂い一種
見ているその時の角度全部出して360度ぴったりになっていればそれは紙で作れるね
ということになってしまうので
ちょっとパティもしれないんですけども
ちょっと前へ仏でしょうか
ということが疑問に思うわけですが
単純に考えるとこの丸いボールのような形であれば
360円いたない
一方でもどんどんアティルということで1枚上手は作れないでということになります
これは数学うやってる人に行き診てもらうなくても直感的にですねまあそうパーマー
リパクスプーン無理でしょ
いう鉄道になるんですがここであきらめてしまわないのが研究
日常を押す
生活の中でちょっと見ていると飴玉を
ラッピングしている神って四角いですね
その市下樋感じでもなんか知らないけどアナルい形を作れてしまっているそれはなぜた
のということです
そそよくよく調べてみると外側に白氏はある姉ということに気付くとそのシュアの分布
をきちんと計算してみるかてぃことに
なるわけですでこれをコンピューターで計算した結果
のアニメーションなんですけどもこのまあるい形もその外側に存在するシワの部分です
きちんと計算して
大将戦を持って配置してあげるとこんな形で
チュッパチャップスを図のような形にもなりますしウェットしか2カ所でギュッと絞る
ということを考えるとも遠投ですね室のような形から
まあるいフォールを包んだような状態につく
ということができると
いうことが言えます
その背景にあるちょっと六ずあの数式と彼は今日は飛ばしちゃいますけれどもその方法
が数式で表すことができるのであればあとはコンピューターにやってもらうことができ
ます
そのためのソフトウェアおり冷房という名前でこれもインターネット上で公開してい
ますので読み方も観ていただければと思う本ソフトウェア
を使ったですね簡単にあっという間に3次元の
そりゃを展示ご覧いただいたような折り紙が設計できてしまいます
できれいに作ってきれいに写真を撮ると
このようにですねあもう歪みなんかすごいねぇとフォークの方に私いってもらうことが
できて嬉しく思ってるんですけども
こういう今までにないような表現ができるようになります
コンピューターのすごいところはですね1回その作り方を教えてしまえばあとはいくら
でも種類を増やせるということです
おいちょっと
形をいじろうかなというふうにするとバリエーション色々増えてどれもこれも1枚の紙
でできるのでレイヤーとをつくってしまうと研究室の中のお読みであるへ帰るという
ような状態になるのです
他なものができてしまうわけですねもちろんあの
そういったソフトウェア板東の2ではないのでできる形に限られています
そういった
限られた中で1はもっと種類を増やそうとするとまた別のソフトウェアを作る
また別のソフトウェアを作るまた別のソフトウェアをつく
そんなことを私は今までやってきた
彼あたしかあーうーどぅっに
すか写真でご紹介しますがこういうものもですね適当に作ったのではなくて後ろには
その計算に基づく設計があると
このような立体的なオブジェと酔う4
ものが
一番紙で作られるようになりました
かあそろっ君クッキー時差をにょ
れて五感ないですけどもこれ1分くらい-6
で全体ではし5分ぐらいて
作ってると思ってください皆さんあのこの曲った星まとめておるんでスカートが気に
なるところだと思いますけども私もさすがに何もない状態でこのきれいな曲線はおれ
ませんので事前に期待
折り筋をつけていますその機会というのもカッティングプロッターああっ女神
まあそんなに特別な機会ではないです
カッターの刃が
前後左右に動いてくれるような機体でうっすらと
なぞってあげると音やすい数字がつきます
あまりに輸出がとつくので映像ではどこにあるかわかんないんですけども
実際に追っていく中ではその場所がキレイ
俺てくれるということで何もない状態から作るよりは here
犀牛とまとめて
できましたということになりますこれくらいの時間で今一つできちゃうんですね
今お見せしたのは六角形の管理から
できていました
六角形
突き詰めることができます
here けども1枚の紙かアティも作ることができます
これ今3つしかないですけどもいくらでもつなげることができるわけですね
そういう発想でデザインしたものをどんどんどんどん拡張していくこれも展開図を編集
して展開図をよく観察することでいろいろ
世界が広がっていくそういったものです
またちょっと今のからですねうつか実例をご紹介しますけど小さいものだけじゃなくて
これはこう
での展示でちょ2m
ですね6メートルぐらいの長さの
か議員がなかなかできないんでダンボールを使いましたけれども
レーサーにしたもの大きいオブジェとして作って体にしようと
いうことをやってみた
今きちんと計算しているので妻はカチッと閉じるわけですね
それからこれもなんか巻貝のような形
いいかなと思ったの
これがですね是非皆さん見ていただきたいのは
コンピューターヌーしました
ってなんか文房具屋さんに商品化してもらえないかと思うんですけどこういう
実際に物体として存在することによって初めて何か新しい発見みたいなもらった
まあこういうものができるとですね実際行為の
これ椅子も使えそうだなあということで
では座ってみましょうとかでそんなことができちゃう
床の音もの方は最初に登場した赤ちゃんで
大きくなってますけども女の一切の折り紙っていうのも楽しい世界の広場んというかな
と言う
ています
あとねになりますけども今まで私は折元としては子供の頃からやってきたものの世界
だけではなくてそこに数学的な知識と後本ケーターの技術そういったものを融合する
ことによって新しい領域が開けるんじゃないかというふうに思っていてこれを
コンペティションの売りが見ハートという風に呼んだりもしてるんですけども
そこで大事になるのはコンピューターでデザインしました
だけではなくてやっぱり人間なんでそこに何か新しいもののでそこにクリエイティブな
活動があると
今までにない新しい折り紙なーとか開けるのではないかなというふうに思ってい
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]